indoor and outdoor spaces are critical
and if you don't understand how to
create a good indoor outdoor connection
your project can simply lack what it's
truly trying to achieve what's going on
guys my name is david thomich and
welcome back to the channel if you're
looking for anything architecture
related then you've come to the right
place today we're going to be looking at
a design that connects the indoors to
the outdoors seamlessly it is going to
be a full archicad 25 model as well as a
twin motion export at the end of the day
to be able to produce high-end renders
as you can see to the left-hand side of
me this process has already started and
i'm going to walk you through it step by
step we're going to break down all the
architectural characteristics of this
and what you can take from it if you're
using this in your own personal project
or simply just looking for inspiration
okay so let me talk to you what has
already happened in this design
basically what we've done is we've been
able to try and create some sort of
indoor outdoor connection by also
dividing our public and private spaces
so to be able to achieve this what we've
really done is defined where the public
spaces are and where the private spaces
are our public spaces in my opinion is
anything where anybody will traverse
through your home or somebody will be
able to see you from the street whereas
a private space is something that is a
little bit more intimate something like
a bedroom or a bathroom is very private
and you want to keep that private away
from everybody else then to be able to
connect this back to our nature we're
constantly looking at ways of basically
immersing this design as best as we can
so continuing on with our public private
connection in this stage of the design
what we're looking at doing is creating
definitive spaces inside the ground
floor the ground floor will comprise of
your formal entry or your foyer then
separated with your eating or dining
areas so your dining room and your
kitchen we then move on to a sunken
lounge which then again clearly defines
one space from another without having to
have a major change in the architecture
this way you can clearly differentiate
the psychology of your dining spaces and
the psychology of your living spaces
where you can actually enjoy something a
little bit more or we have to have a
formal meal the best thing about these
spaces being sunken moved shifted and
separated from each other is that we are
able to then clear division around our
backyard if in this instance it was a
rectangular block and we only had four
sides to work with we have the maximum
ability to be able to provide views from
almost all sides nobody really wants to
be looking back towards the street
unless you're looking for some sort of
passive surveillance however we do
really want to be enjoying what we're
experiencing inside of our own design
most people don't have the luxury and
liberty of living on hectares and
hectares worth of land instead they have
a small piece of paradise that they all
use every single day and want to enjoy
every single day when we move upstairs
we really want to move up into those
private spaces a little bit more whilst
still connecting back to our piece of
paradise that we've created in our
backyard by limiting the actual size of
the house we have that ability to
increase the size of our paradise per se
upstairs we're really focusing on our
private spaces our intimate moments so
our bedrooms our bathrooms our small
activity room that might be used for
kids or anybody in the meantime that's
basically just passing through those
spaces without making it too formal in
this case we're using it as a pool table
area which can be changed into anything
that you'd prefer but basically what
we're trying to achieve is two master
bedroom spaces that are continuously
looking outside to our indoor outdoor
connection whilst we also have two
additional bedrooms it can be one it can
be three it the concept is the same
nonetheless that are basically filtering
light so in this instance we are
connecting back to the indoor outdoor
spaces not in a visual connection they
say through to that greenery through to
that water but instead we are connecting
to the light and to the nature so as the
sun passes over this entire project you
can see the light filter and trickle
through the blades into the bedrooms
themselves really creating a soft
delicate space and this can be used as
well when people are potentially
overlooking your site or you're directly
looking at somebody else's neighboring
property this is a great way really to
separate without separating from the
outdoors itself now we always want to
also be able to create some sort of
actual outdoor spaces so balconies are
an incredibly easy incredibly effective
way to do this even if they are a tiny
little juliet balcony off your master
bedroom it is enough to be able to stand
outside get some fresh air and truly
appreciate what you've spent a long time
designing long time creating and most
likely even longer building
when we do get to our backyard and our
little piece of paradise as i like to
call it we really want to focus on
what's important to us so if that means
you truly want a 10 meter pool or a 20
meter pool you want to find out a way of
how you can introduce that into the
design there's nothing worse than having
to come back and go that wasn't actually
what i wanted i wanted a lot more from
that design especially if you had the
ability to do something about it so in
this instance i always try to like to
keep the water as close to the property
as possible because once the water is
close to the property it also allows
that sunlight to basically reflect off
the water and shine onto the actual
property itself reflecting onto the
ceilings of the indoor spaces that you
get to enjoy every single day when
you're at home now when we're actually
looking this at a rendering point of
view we're looking at it from a comfort
point of view we're looking at it from
an actual experiential point of view so
we're looking at how the light travels
over the pathway how it looks from the
street what people will be seeing and
what you'll be experiencing as you come
home to your beautiful luxury bespoke
home now in this instance we again are
trying to connect that indoor outdoor
feeling so as soon as you're coming back
to your house you really want to be
connecting back to nature as much as
possible so to be able to do this what
we've done in this design is basically
broken up the landscaping areas as much
as we can so you're immersed as much as
possible now there might be a house to
the left and right of you but you can
still filter that house away through
planter boxes or even garden beds and in
this instance we've introduced that main
garden bed into the center of this
design which could then also be elevated
further with some garden and some
greenery potentially some grass around
the side but what you want to experience
is when you're coming home you're
experiencing that native emotion you're
experiencing coming back into nature
coming back into your paradise the
actual landscaping that we've selected
in this is very very native to the
program itself it is all very tropical
so we don't have too much control over
the landscaping unless we really want to
see this computer crash and absolutely
have
no final result at the end of the day
but what we've gone for is a tropical
paradise here basically just some really
nice deep greens that are constantly
green throughout the year they're
evergreen plants they're not deciduous
because they don't need to be at such a
low height we're also focusing on the
ability to be able to walk from your car
into your garage into your house through
your front door around the backyard
whichever way you go to be always
connected back to that nature
now i'm a qualified architect i'm not a
qualified landscape architect so i have
no idea about trees and plants and
selections but i do know what does look
good and when we do work with landscape
architects they're there to be able to
actually identify and further bring this
project to reality and to the actual
vision that we're all sharing to be able
to actually come home to something that
is enjoyable now not everybody will have
a porsche out the front of their house
but it is the only high-end quality car
that i have so that's what we're going
with at the moment and nonetheless it is
still being connected back to nature as
much as possible even though that is a
man-made human element it is something
that we want to be taking into
consideration because we don't want to
forget about that at all in the rear of
the property the same concept applies
we're really connecting that water back
to that greenery back to the grass as
much as we possibly can so that no
matter where you stand in the house no
matter where you're looking you're
always connecting back to the greenery
you're always connecting back to the
grass and the water even if it's through
little glimpses of windows or little
pockets of light we always always want
to be trying our best to be able to
connect back to that greenery back to
the outdoors as much as we possibly can
even if that is just a small piece of
fresh air from a balcony or the giant
leaves of a palm tree or a pine tree
simply cantilevering and falling over
the spaces that you're inhabiting at the
moment anyway that's all for me today
guys thank you so much for watching i
hope you enjoyed the video i hope you
learned something new if you did make
sure you smash that like button down
below and don't forget about subscribe
button but like i said that is all from
me so i will see you next monday